hey how's it going bros - motapod so
today's video is a little bit special
because this game I played it a while
ago and the guys who made this game ah
needed funding for it and I said hey I
love your game I want to help out so I
actually have funding this game I love
this game it may be a little biased but
it's been really inspiring to see how
much hard work they really put into this
project it's so cool and I think you
bros are really gonna love it as well so
if you are interested by it please do
check out the game a liberal link to an
inscription and that's it for now I
don't want to try and oversell it just
because of that I am just gonna let the
gameplay speak for itself so it is
point-and-click horror game in a very
very cute
style as you can see ball boy here so
kawaai but without further ado let's
play ball boy good all bull people it
starts off in their bold mansion I don't
know if that's what it's called I like
how the moon is a delightful makes sense
I played pieces of the game I haven't
played it all consecutively so I can
already see a bunch of references all
over the room it's awesome okay so I
need to go to bed Lexus it's a point and
click game so let's explore a little bit
first so cute come on grandpa oh god
[ __ ] okay we have grandpa's teeth I
didn't know we needed them better
apparently we do let's check out the
television there's a few cool stuff here
we got he-man I would also forgot is
that I turned off the TV Oh
oh god is that the ring oh [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
change change okay I think this is alien
isn't it yeah what happens if we leave
it turned a power glove
awesome I think you use it for the
television we need to tell of it okay
ball-ball be calm down mate okay so we
want the teeth and the TV off but I
think we need a TV on to use the power
glove so let's try that again see what
happens yeah I think we can put the
teeth in here let's try it
I love pointing late games like this cuz
it's it has so much charm and it's just
so much fun just to click around and see
what's gonna happen there we go it's
called Edgar I'm just gonna call him
Edgar for now who can fly awesome
alright doing get
Oh God
okay that sounds great how could you not
wake up from that hey Sookie
and you see why I love this game it's so
awesome that's me when I wake up in the
morning
something has happened we heard our
grandpa call alright let's go over here
see what we got okay Bobby the spider
wants us to find a bunch of bugs
I have fun back there but we can't quite
reach it it's not an intense Tetris yeah
alright we're gonna have to find
something that helps us reach let's
check here what do we get what happens
if we click on this and then this
oh yeah we gotta let it through I
remember this come on mate you're right
there it goes first try maybe now you
got son son of a [ __ ] oh we got him
whoa
first try [ __ ] what about mr.
bunny here oh here we go
that's seem useful and now let's use
this on this come here mate um I think
you're attractive fly with a light if I
remember so let's try and click on this
okay you can't let go now ball B boy
there you go all right we did it
there you go mate take this I feel a
little bad doing this I don't know maybe
it's just me will you leave me alone now
please what the [ __ ]
okay that's a little creepy okay now we
are here hi yeah did he say crap ooh can
I hear let's check here whatever gap
looks like we need a key no way yeah we
need a key let's check out Oh God I've
got him geared we're all slimed in what
do we do oh well we're a ball boy so we
can do this [ __ ] makes sense doesn't it
all right let's go over here and now
okay
oh we [ __ ] out open on that ever again
we're good okay here we go
there you go you see our body follows us
downstairs oh god oh god we're not safe
quite yet keep going the [ __ ] are these
paintings meant ooh okay now we're back
on track don't be scared ball boy I'm
right would you make we're gonna be a
statue even that's that's always useful
we're a bit rusty that I'm so glad I
thought there's the key isn't it yeah I
don't remember that I'll take it
yep that's that's how you do it okay
what do we got what do we got in here
oil maybe that's useful let's try it
I really hope like if this game gets
popular that we can do plushies of ball
boy because he's so cute who wouldn't
want a ball boy plushie come on there we
go let's all this pitch up right on the
nipple that's everyone knows that's how
you do it
okay they are miss out we're scared when
we know how to fight now ball boy is a
strong warrior Oh God wouldn't have the
play do we [ __ ] dammit really awesome
music so check out the window I think
there are some references that flappy
bird flapping away ooh a shard
interesting okay maybe we can use that
at the blade boom bada boom
say hello to Sim salabim that hand is so
disgusting
I don't even know where to begin now
let's cut that [ __ ] [ __ ] off mate
oh god damn it
that's disgusting grandpa what are you
do Oh No oh he's so cute
grandpa what are you doing grandpa wake
up grandpa better get his teeth out
don't shoot me No
yes let's pour the water on him now
that'll do the trick
sorry grandpa grew I love you but this
is for you I worked you're right you're
right Gramps oh I hear some noises
let's check the Troy oh okay you guys
are disgusting I'm gonna go out of here
in a couple couple hours I'm sure we'll
be there no problem you can you can do
it bubbly boy isn't it awesome so far ha
ha ha this is the memory about that one
time we were having a picnic in the park
there's fluffy bird alive awesome nice
okay he needs a tennis ball all right I
got you man
of course we grab the egg and we give it
to good old fluffy flu and then once the
egg hits flat damn it
I remember this puzzle it's really
complicated if we throw it but then flap
is like oh god I hate him
god I love music it's so good beside
miss Merrick I don't know what I'm doing
though the egg is right there mate
oh the tree branch okay thanks so that's
good it's so annoying when he gets to
suck even if I know what I'm doing okay
there we go awesome there you go
oh we got the bar whoo poor old flapper
though let's let's give him the egg I
don't want to be a dick there you go man
not a problem I'm the man of the people
good old flappy bird yeah look at his
flappers
oh yeah so this is the memory where we
learn teach him how to fly and now we
learn it it's a beautiful moment it
flies away with the chicken it's a core
memory amazing all right I'm gonna pause
this video here if you enjoyed watching
leave a like but most of all I didn't
want to say to Simon Archer who made
this game and everyone part of all where
you guys should be so proud you've done
an amazing job uh it's so awesome I love
this game I know I'm biased of course
take that in mind but if you are
interested in the game please please do
check it out I'll leave a link to the
description I highly recommend it and
it's way better than watching me play
except have some fun if you are bored
and Al Sieber us in the next one that's
always thanks for watching
say awesomeness hey a slicker
hey give it oh [ __ ] I gotta play it cool